bom dia bom dia bom dia a gente tá indo
para outro treino Claro né tem como ti
para o mesmo treino sempre que já foi
feito pegar a bênção
né tá sempre bom vem com a gente hoje eu
vou de carro
mesmo então acho que eu não vou nem
botar aquele ontem porque não rendeu
é a Então agora você vai conhecer a
academia com a gente e já dar um treino
com nós camão beab nós vamos nessa nessa
vanzinha aqui ó tem várias dessas aqui
na ilha
pronto acompanha
aí dar uma paródia aqui que eu vou
soltar Eita
[Música]
eita
Essa é academia que a gente treina tem
uma vista muito bonita lá de cima daqui
não dá para ver mas eu vou te eu vou te
mostrar tem algumas pequenas escadas até
chegar lá lugar onde treina
né Toda vez tem que subir isso
aqui
[Música]
aqui Chapa aí estre aí
ó
agora fica bom treinar assim né como é
que vai ser o treino
hoje hoje nós vamos dar uma aquecida
agora rápida aí TR minutinhos só na
corda umzinho de sombra com peso na
sequência Vamos colocar luva Vamos bater
C round aqui ó governadora trabalhar um
pouco da força mão de trás do W que tá
forte Vamos explorar isso depois nós
vamos trabalhar manopla livre velocidade
trabalhar parte técnica e alguma
coisinha no final aí
[Música]
acompanha
aqui é o aquecimento
viu não começou não treinar Ainda não
Que que isso aqui faz com os ombros essa
a posição de segurar guarda alto né mano
é você precisa ter uma resistência Toy
exato então precisa fazer muito trabalho
de resistência ficar cansado os braços
não ir descendo como você tá acostumado
já com ele aqui no alto na hora que seu
braço tiver baixando ele não vai baixar
aqui entendeu ele vai continuar pelo
menos na linha do rosto de cima vai
baixar poucos centímetros
BX Bora
[Aplausos]
[Música]
preparou
cara abriu contag PR ti
a perdi pra governadora
Man governo man5
round radura não anginha aqui ah mas nem
vomitou tá zo é não vomitar
tá no banheiro mee fora logo mano
vomit
vomitar aí ó aí ó tá direita aí agora
esquerda
saiu só a maçã que eu comi n instante
Será que era maçã tava
po
is
vai minuto
abdominal desca
Bora curtinho curtinho
curtinho aqui
tira
parabén
Caral foi bom PR [__] ah passar mal
todos os é melhor né cansado ali no
sexto sexto PR frente todos cansado mas
só de aguentar se sem vontade de vomitar
já achei totalmente diferente de todos
os dias
galerinha acabamos o treino de hoje aqui
em
GR
nome
GR cons aqui na conqu
e e é isso é segundo TR né é segundo dia
de camp segundo dia de camp São 38
dias sei lá vamos vamos no dia que
acabar mulher di aí nós acaba a mulher
que mulher aí sim l l l pode ser essa
essa aqui é
pr blusa
Tailândia aí a blusa Tailândia que eu
ganhei
ó aí
ó